And now the old Scoutmasters.
Why is a room full of Scoutmasters like a box of matches?
They're both full of heads. they can't think, but that will strike anywhere.
This is podcast number 186..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Paul Simonetti wrote in to say this: I'm about to become a Scoutmaster.
I've only been a Cubmaster for four years and I'll be replacing a legendary Scoutmaster.
So to help me prepare, I found your podcast and I've listened to the first 25 or so.
So if you mentioned this one on air in your next podcast- and I did, Paul, here it is
right now.
I hope to get to it by the end of next year.
Thanks for your perspectives and thanks for keeping the podcast going.
Many of us are verbal learners and we can toss your podcast into an MP3 player and listen
to it while we're walking or driving or exercising or something like that.
I'm certain one of the reasons that I can relate to you is that you've stated somewhere
that you were never a Scout and I wasn't either.
Thanks again,
Keep making those podcasts.
One day I'll be caught up with you and you'll interview me, and it will be magnificent.
Well, Paul, I'm sure you're going to make a fine Scoutmaster.
It'll be a little bit different than your Cubmaster experience, I'm sure, but that's pretty good
preparation for the job.
Also heard from Bill Duncan, who said: thanks, Clark, as a Scoutmaster I always look for
your email alerts and I walk away with something new to think about, not only for our troop
but for each Scout and our leaders.
Thanks, Bill.
Thanks for the kind words and thanks for getting in touch.
You can email me, Clark, at ScoutmasterCGcom. it's C-L-A-R-K-E at ScoutmasterCGcom.
Visit us at the Scoutmaster blog and check that out, and you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog by email once you're there, and there's a contact form on there
too, if you'd like to use that.
Last night I got together with Arlam Ward for our September Scout Circle and our guest
was Derek Hansen, and Derek is the author of The Ultimate Hang, which is the book on hammock
camping.
If you're not familiar with hammock camping, it's something you really ought to get to
know.
We recorded our discussion and lots of people sent in questions and we had a great time.
so make sure you go to ScoutmasterCGcom's YouTube channel and you can watch the presentation
there.
Our next Scout Circle presentation is going to be October 13th. that's a Sunday.
It happens between 9 and 10 pm Eastern Standard Time and what happens is we have a live presentation
that's followed up by your questions.
If you have questions about backpacking, and specifically about scouts and backpacking,
you can start emailing now, and you can do that at the same email address: Clark at
ScoutmasterCGcom, C-L-A-R-K-E at ScoutmasterCGcom.
If you haven't gotten in on one of the Scout Circle deals. it's a lot of fun, so make
sure that you put Sunday, October 13th on your schedule and we'll see you then.
One important thing to note is that the Boy Scouts of America recently released their
initial implementation resources addressing the change to membership standards voted on
at this year's meeting in May.
Part of the resources that they've provided to date is a frequently asked questions for
unit leaders document, and I'll make sure to link to it in the post that contains this
podcast, and I mentioned it on the blog within the past week or so.
You want to make sure to look at that because it provides initial guidance on implementation
of this membership change and just to give you a condensed overview. not much changes
With anything at all in the day-to-day workings of a troop program.
As always, we always apply our training and available resources to presenting the program
in the way that best benefits and serves the interests of our Scouts.
When this change goes into effect at the first of next year, our task as leaders is to
address any practical concerns that arise once it does, and the way that we do that
is the way that we do everything else:
By asking the question: what's in the best interest of the youth that we serve? and we
apply the good judgment that we've developed over our experience and through our training.
Now, as the debate was brewing this past spring, questions of accommodations and
logistics arose, and the FAQ document that I mentioned answered these questions with
very clear, unambiguous language. a few bullet points.
Sexual orientation is not a youth protection issue.
We're going to focus on the best interest of our Scouts and assure that there's an
atmosphere of goodwill.
It's clear that equanimity, care for the concerns of our youth members and their
families and addressing those concerns wisely is always dependent on us, as unit
level volunteers, applying good judgment.
I know that there are a lot of differing levels of comfort and acceptance
with the new membership standards, and my best advice to all of us is to
review the materials that the BSA has published very carefully with an open mind.
One of the things referred to in these materials is there's going to be
additional training material to be released this fall.
I'll keep my eyes open for it and share any further information with you, both on
the blog and here in the podcast.
In this podcast and Scout Master's ship in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about sharing information with our youth leaders.
We do this in training.
We do it in mentoring.
We're going to talk a little bit about how we go about doing that effectively,
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Master's ship in seven minutes or less.
So we're working with our youth leaders. when we're mentoring them or
training them or advising them,
We're doing a couple of different things.
First of all, we're sharing information with them, and information is great.
It educates and directs and helps make things clearer,
And we know that having that information is good,
but it's only experience that develops skill.
Sharing information is good, but I'll tell you something,
especially when it relates to our youth leadership,
too much information can be paralyzing.
We live in the information age.
Our scouts get plenty of information and much more than any of us can
effectively do anything with.
What we really need is being able to take what information we receive
and apply it and gain experience from that.
Scouting is an educational movement,
but it's not educational in the traditional sense.
Scouting is a journey through experiences that develop skill.
It's not just this body of information that we impart to our scouts.
Sometimes we get a little mixed up.
We think our scouts need a lot of information to develop skills
and they don't.
I think we get a little mixed up when we're talking about
training adult leaders with this.
We think they need lots of information.
They don't.
What they really need is experience,
and this is true of almost everything we do in scouting.
So if you have ever taught someone how to ride a bike,
think about that for a moment.
What would you do?
We get a bike out, we put them in the seat,
we give them a couple of pointers
and we tell them to try it out.
The first couple of tries aren't going to work very well,
probably, but as they start to figure things out,
we coach them and we encourage them
and we work with them until, through experience,
they've developed enough skill to go ahead and ride a bike. right
When we're instructing scouts or working with scouts on a skill
like building a campfire or safely handling a pocket knife
or flipping a flapjack.
we're giving them the information that they need at the time
and they are applying it in a very hands-on kind of an atmosphere,
and there's not necessarily a lot of talking going on,
but there's a lot of action,
there's a lot of experience being gained.
So how do we apply this to training or mentoring
or advising our youth leaders?
Unfortunately, a lot of our training,
both for youth and adults,
is aimed at sharing information.
More often than not, what we do is we plop people down
in front of a PowerPoint presentation or a video
and we give them lots of handouts
and then we say, okay, now you have the information,
now you've been trained.
But that is just the beginning, isn't it?
Once somebody has the information, they have to act on it.
When they act on it, they gain the experience.
When they gain the experience, then they become skilled,
and that very simple concept is what we are all about, isn't it?
Measuring out the information we share
with our youth leaders is important.
It's not because we want to keep secrets
or we don't want to reveal to them what's going to happen next,
but because we want them to get the amount of information
they need to act. and then what?
Gain an experience and develop skill.
So I have right now a new senior patrol leader
that was elected during our week at summer camp
and he had his first patrol leaders council meeting last week.
I could sit him down and I could sit the new patrol leaders council down
and I could start sharing information with them,
to the point that they would become totally overloaded
and they're really not sure what to do next.
Now, because I am a talker and I love to talk,
I could have started out with their job descriptions
and then probably followed 17 different rabbit trails
on each bullet point of those job descriptions.
Pretty soon, you know, about 10 minutes into
my sharing information, their eyes would kind of glaze over,
their heads would begin to nod,
their feet would begin to shuffle,
because those are all indications that I have overloaded them.
I have told them more than they need to know.
What they're anxious for is the information
that they need to know. right then.
What I did was I sat down with the senior patrol leader
for about five minutes
and I asked him some questions about the content
of his patrol leaders council meeting.
What are you going to do?
Do you have it written down?
If you write down what you're going to do at a meeting,
do you know what that's called?
That's called an agenda.
An agenda is a pretty important thing to have.
If you share that agenda with people
before you get to the meeting,
they're going to be more prepared for it.
Now is that something that you did,
And we went along like that for about five minutes.
We talked about the very practical things
that he needed to do,
and then I stopped talking.
I left the room.
I let the patrol leaders council go ahead
and sit there and get to work.
I didn't sit in on their meeting.
I didn't guide their meeting.
I didn't do anything else other than
give them the pertinent information
they needed for the next half hour or so.
Now my next move was to go out
and to work with my junior assistant,
Scott Masters.
They're 16 or 17 years old.
They're very experienced guys.
They understand what all the youth leadership
positions are and how to do them well,
And I gave them enough information
so that they could get started basically
doing my job right.
I'm going to be there
and I'm going to be working along with everybody,
but I want these junior assistant, Scott Masters
to work with the senior patrol leader
and the patrol leaders council
in the same way that I usually would.
But I have these great, experienced guys,
so it's time for them to go to the next level
and to learn about the job that Scott Masters do.
Because what are they?
They're junior assistant Scott Masters.
So we talked about different ways
that they could support the patrol leaders council
and the senior patrol leader.
We talked about what I'm talking about right now,
which is, hey, if you're going to talk
to the senior patrol leader, remember
he doesn't need to know everything that you know right now.
He needs to know what he needs to know
for the next few things that he needs to accomplish
And what we're doing right now in our troop.
we've got a couple of different levels of this going.
Things go better if I give my youth leadership
the most pertinent information
that they read right now to get their job done
and let them work on that piece of information,
let them gain some experience from applying it.
then we'll reflect on that experience
and the developing skills that they have
and then they'll get the next bit of information:
Somebody learning how to ride a bike,
scouts learning how to handle a pocket knife
or build a fire.
They need brief, concise, informational statements
and then lots of practice and a little coaching
as they practice along.
Then the final step is to get them to reflect
on the way that they applied the information that was shared.
How did it work?
How did it go?
What are you going to do differently next time?
What do you think you did well?
What do you think you can improve on?
And we do this not an hour long sessions,
but kind of in real time.
We take a couple of minutes here,
a couple of minutes there.
We have a patrol leaders council meeting once a month.
The patrol leaders council gets together
before the troop meeting to check on their preparations
and after the troop meeting to reflect on the meeting
and check on their preparations for next time.
And in those times my most important tool is my ears.
I'm listening to what they say,
I'm listening to their discussions with one another,
I'm observing what they're doing during meetings,
during campouts, looking at the interactions
that are happening,
And then I'm giving them the information
I think they need to move on to the next step of skill development.
So let's remember, you know,
as denizens of the information age.
there's a lot of stuff out there.
We can take all the information that we know.
we can dump it on somebody and say,
okay, now you got it, see you later.
But the best approach is that riding a bike approach right,
Giving them what they need right. then
letting them digest that, internalize it,
take it, make it into experiences,
that sharpen skills, reflect on the experience
and help them see what they're getting right
and what they maybe need to improve on.
And then we move on to the next challenge.
Well, thanks so much for listening,
And here's how to keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog at scoutmastercgcom
While you're there. you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
when you do
Leave a comment or review a rating, if you have the time.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
And you can get details about how to make that happen
at stitchercom.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter
And watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
And, for admittance to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle,
search for ScoutmasterCG on Google Plus
If you have not yet stepped in to the vast panorama
of social media. well, you know what
Bunky? zoom in to the 90s and send me an email.
That's right,
You can email me, Clark Green, your comments, questions
and wild ideas at Clark C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom.
It's Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are in no way official publications
to the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone
and trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
And speaking of fun, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.